Tell me if you can relate to this.
You were an avid reader of fiction as a kid.
The Harry Potter series, The Hunger Games, Bobby Pendragon, Percy Jackson.
You ate them like ice cream; you drank them like water in summertime...
...after running around at the park.
You would spend hours in your bedroom, in another world, in another universe.
I was one of those kids.
That was my experience growing up.
But somewhere along the line, like early teenage years, that all ended.
I'm not sure it's a coincidence...
...that I got my first smartphone when I was 14 years old.
Suddenly, there were a lot of other things capturing my attention,...
...you know, better things to do.
I feel like many of us who are now in our 20s and 30s went through this.
I mean, I went years without reading anything...
...outside of what I was required to read at school.
Last year, though, I rediscovered books,...
...and now they are my very favorite way to absorb new information.
I honestly think that every single book I have ever read...
...has changed me and my perspective of the world in some way.